pot lounges they're now legal here in
nevada they have been since the
legislative session the question is when
will they open the nevada cannabis
compliance board says they are getting
everything ready it's a slow process
john muller sat down with the board's
executive director and has more on a
potential timeline
we were the first dispensary to open in
city of las vegas frank hawkins is one
of the owners of nevada wellness center
this is the consumption lounge
that has been ready for about two years
despite it being legal he can't open
this lounge just yet not until
regulation has been created by the
new ccb we sat down with the executive
director of the ccb or cannabis
compliance board tyler klemis so if
everything goes well we'll probably
see the first consumption lounges open
up mid-year next year from public safety
to health concerns klamas says the board
is working on the rules and regulations
needed for the lounges a lot of that has
to do with the licensing
and the application of consumption
lounges they expect the application
period to open in the spring the process
could take a few months existing
dispensaries can apply to add a lounge
for a hundred thousand dollar
non-refundable application fee 20
independent lounges will be permitted
for a smaller not yet determined fee
half of those independent lounges per
the legislation
will be held and awarded to social
equity applicants further increasing the
in inclusiveness and diversity the board
is still figuring out exactly who will
qualify as a social equity applicant
then you'll come in front of the board
and you'll address the board and the
board will either deem you suitable or
not suitable to open a license joe
mohler live local now
the climate says those in the industry
can get updates through workshops or
public meetings they do expect to have a
large universal meeting about the rules
and regulations coming up in december